ciao ragazzi bentornato della puntata di
cucina ha buttato un po di tempo fa
abbiamo fatto un tiramisù utilizzando la
testa di un dinosauro e l'esperimento è
andato benissimo ora il tiramisù
effettivamente è una cosa che tutti
quanti sanno fare quindi molto
probabilmente penserete di non aver
bisogno di guardare questo video e
invece no perché oggi cercheremo di fare
un tiramisù un pochino diverso dal
solito un pochino più professionale ed
ecco perché non lo farò io ma lo farà il
real nei tornei con la pasticcera che
conosciamo perché faceva box con enrico
fondamentalmente e andavi a scuola al
liceo conoscen oggi che facciamo
praticamente facciamo il tiramisù più
spettacolare della tua vita ammazzare
sono una palla il cioccolato da
tantissimi video di palla e si diverte
con dentro tiramisù quelli che si
sciolgono perché stiamo perfetto quindi
a questo punto io direi innanzitutto di
cambiarci perchè così tu hai il tavolo
davanti visto che non farò niente e di
soprattutto inaugurare che si chiama la
parannanza il grembiule il grembiule
dell'ospite per fare il tiramisù più
spettacolare che mangeremo maniere
nostra intera esistenza avremo bisogno
di zucchero farina 00 nuova app
assaggiare un nuovo si dice così
cioccolato fondente
ma questo è un cioccolato particolare
con una percentuale di burro di cacao
maggiore poggi se siete delle persone
basse e pezzenti a noi non ce ne frega
niente perché oggi noi vi indicheremo le
nostre origini cola mascarpone questo e
per darci la carica che robbie è roba da
fichi la parte esterna della fava di
cacao che è stata secca tato stata e poi
banche mancanza mantra pata ecco in
termine tecnico che cosa dobbiamo fare
quando irene ha detto a gianmarco quasi
sempre stati gli ingredienti per questa
ricetta a panna
lui ha portato la panna che lamentare la
carbonara francese invece no panna
fresca dire tutti una progressione netta
pari a zero c'è il caffè si santifica
del caffè così importante non dire un
disordine
partiamo subito da una parte più
difficile savoiardi comprarli estivo ma
è un po lavoraccio
davvero colpa sua e le vengono più buoni
di friabili di tutto non se vengono bene
se vengono penso mi sento una pittorici
note sull'india le tavole che non pesa
affatto tre album non permettersi
pressione però se va una sola luce di
torno all'interno dell'album e non molto
correttamente non permettete impressione
naturalmente aiutare una vita che separò
tuorli dagli albumi e puntualmente
scritta sara ti sei un povero ragazzo
sono veloce persone un altro vorrei
provare quello che si vede su internet
si chiama bottigliette di respirare
grazie non potuto anche fare che questo
acquistato un ottimo metodo una carezza
vabbè per renderlo un crack 45 grammi di
zucchero 45 memoria di tipo dovrei
leggere per avere visioni rimontiamo
insieme più o meno adesso vedrai che non
ci arrivano mai
ma perché così c'è il calore moderno
capita così che produzione si montano ma
io sono ma enorme st spina stanno
schiumando quindi aggiungiamo un po di
zucchero
mai e ora possiamo stare ma era la cosa
che del ragazzo si amministrazioni non
si volta lo zucchero avete letto io bond
a 50 grammi di farina e 17 di sera
quindi perché vinto una farina come lo
so metto mai marisa la padova poi che ti
do marisa dobbiamo prepararci il sac à
poche secondo lei si dice il sun
capoccione la sacca porta alla secondo
me ci sia capace per dicono la saga
coscia ma berbatov è così che tenterà
come quelle più professionali però siamo
pasticceria ti regala il sorriso esatto
aspetta un altro pozzo non stavo fino a
domani
lentamente dal basso verso l'alto leggi
la foto di un altro verso che fai ti
fanno così si smonta per ogni trattarlo
come come se fosse un figlio sì esatto
non alla classe non ci sto il lievito
alpine savoiardi fanno parte della
famiglia di pan di spagna e nessuno ci
rimane male quando lo dico lo sarei poi
uno e tu l'hai mai altri episodi
io mi sento sempre lui al posto di
marisa perché mi dà felicità quando è
vera non lo giro e poi è scomodo e
almeno poi sempre sarà colpa lui e non a
te stesso che mi sento antonella clerici
quindi come funziona adesso si mette il
greco mar attentamente è un pannello di
zac apposta al crema e informiamo gli
facciamo mini o big tutti così ok si
bing così pure mi voglia sono carini
allora li fanno tutti i minimi a non è
un mitra comunque ma un po una lumaca
enrico faccio vedere tu che sono merigo
tra l'altro questi lavori si mostra
terni con un mitra userà attimo bene
bene gianmarco
vi prego facci vedere come non si fa sì
ma io darei una piccola spolverata di
zucchero a velo che non abbiamo
abbiamo sì sì no no no
ecco lo zucchero quindi cela infatti
tutti quindi se va male 1 vanno mano
tutti in pratica si io ti ringrazio per
avermi fermato proprio quando ho finito
inforniamo per dieci barra 15 minuti in
un forno a 180 gradi
l'ho appena letto è lesto pure male così
scritto venti minuti dai step da 30
secondi la volontà di questo cioccolato
da me
buonissimo maniera mescolate con un
cucchiaio casa brucia e non a membri
professionista d'alto livello non ha mai
introducendo il cioccolato te lo giuro
pazzesco meno mia di noi gli facciamo
sopra ma io e cerca di rimanere sempre
dentro sia alla sfera e controlliamo
meravigliosi savoiardi c'è uniti
altissimo che termine tecnico che
perdono tantissimo
va bene al freezer quello che abbiamo
fatto adesso è stata una cosa da basi lo
possiamo dirlo si dice che anche il
livello è un po basso non vogliamo fare
quello con la bottiglia e vedere se
funzionando alle lascia falla aveva
preso una bottiglia della spazzatura
canalis pensa quella signora croato che
di la mozione è presente che ogni volta
il tiramisù pezzo sempre un rischio di
morire esatto si anch'io penso che in
realtà dovresti diciamo pastorizzare con
la meringa ora va da bombe
cosa ho sbagliato no lo deve tenere
premuto vero non temere per risucchiarlo
aspettare che altri dentro ma un peccato
può esprimere così ma scusa la colpa di
chi è l'ultima volta sei anni perché non
ci ha creduto veramente fronte savoiardi
che dicono pronti se non altro
chiediamo
noi prendiamo qua e non mischiare certo
io so fingendo ricordato come le
pastorizzato adesso lo scaldiamo al
microonde a 60 gradi che è una bassa
pastorizzazione cioè perché voleva al
peggio capito ok allora 10 g di acqua e
40 grammi di zucchero tutto qua dentro
ebbene se io solitamente in realtà non
faccio questo procedimento lui legava
direttamente la riserva sorprese intera
notte
paolo come è normale che sappia di nuovo
ci siamo resi conto usando tantissimo il
microonde che sa poco di abb è un
grembiule insomma c'è il senso era bravo
a piatti sporchi in vita tua stai per
favore questo è il giusto
e ieri
[Musica]
quindi io posso fare questo senza paura
di morire pregio adesso montiamo panna
mascarpone allora s'è spenta un secondo
dalla telecamera quindi non sappiamo se
visto il montaggio è la mamma comasca
ruolo ho rischiato quasi di fare il
burro ma forse è salva nessuno buttiamo
questa roba qua dentro
amalgamiamo con delicatezza non sono
tanti in giro
hai visto la serie è certo la baita
occhio così trasmondi ma per andare ad
arrivare alla carta eppure un pò
liquidità per interrare bene
nell'aspetto perché abbiamo non toccare
dalla poesia sono di mangone di tale
perfetto dobbiamo acquistare la sul
piatto sul piatto ecco l'idea come
fissare la voce colatura do un attimo
passati nel caveau le tutto incrostato
purtroppo
ecco io non si può bruciare qualcosa che
sta bruciando mettere più dritto che
puoi il perché di una paese sottoposta
cetica così che forse però una ricetta
perché siete in tanti nomi niente dove
parlare non ho favor catalettica scaduto
fuori li dobbiamo rompere perché devono
e moras anche benissimo al casello
niente niente
noi qui in quanto due senza
così si può adesso cielo sporchi un po
intorno non è una lettera da sì io non
so cosa aspettarmi ha infatti durante
bene dove sono commossa così a scordare
il passato ci siamo scontrati in bassa
ma è meglio per i vostri bambini fidati
che lamentano se mi viene sempre cercare
per un qualcosa di appuntito
miccoli non ora sapere per sarkozy ma
non ce l'abbiamo e c'è un lato
consigliato in ultimo di rosario la
tazzina perché cominciare non cercare
ovunque ma è perché non hai il tuo conto
maestro 7 quella maledizione che dice
perché non viene mai niente eccoci qua
se diversi piano in realtà si è sciolto
che questa non savoiardo dovrà essere
più grande per fare per implodere
comunque possiamo dire che è vera una
cosa che su cucina buttata io vorrei
passare un attimo all'assaggio più figo
ragazzi però se ne mangia tutti i tuoi
anni esperimento per versare la farina
cercate di avere un pezzettino qualcosa
che vi faccio andare e poi è un po più
elegante di irene più ti ringrazio di
cuore per esserti prestato in questa
probabilità che un piacere ciò che tu
hai standard sono più alti un po come
jasmine è bello mischiarsi capito
insieme a lei e agli stracci proveniente
anche siamo in grazia te per la tua
falsità
ragazzi se volete seguire le sue
creazioni se volete seguire tutto quello
che fa viva su qua sotto i tuoi link
instagram
mi metterò qua sotto anche un infobox un
sacco di altre magari informazioni dalle
dosi sacco di altre robe che le ruberò
adesso è che rivenderemo insieme alla
sua maglietta noi giriamo la prossima
domenica sempre alle 12 con un altro
episodio di cucina buttata ciao ciao